mariupol une ville assiégée bombardée
sans répit où les habitants paient le
prix fort la croix rouge parle d'une
situation déchirante dans ce grand port
de 500000 habitants il n'y a plus d'eau
d'électricité d'essence depuis plusieurs
jours la ville a une importance
stratégique pour les russes sa conquête
permettrait de relier les territoires
séparatistes du donbass à la crim est
annexée par la russie il y a huit ans ce
matin lueur d'espoir russe et ukrainien
se mettent d'accord sur un couloir
humanitaire menant à zaporizhya
aussitôt des centaines de personnes se
massent dans les rues dans la tente d'un
départ espoir déçu deux heures plus tard
les russes nous ont dit que la route de
marioupol azapo ridja est sûr mais nous
avons reçu des informations selon
lesquelles il ya de violents combats sur
cette route
ensuite ils continuent à bombarder
marioupol donc nous avons demandé aux
habitants de ne pas rester à attendre
dans la rue
cet après-midi les russes rejette la
faute sur les ukrainiens
que nous avons été informés que les
autorités de marioupol refuse de donner
aux habitants la possibilité de partir
par le couloir humanitaire oui tu pour
une mise en place par l'armée russe
voyait
le dernier convoi avoir pu quitter
marioupol c'était il ya trois jours
juste avant que les russes encerclent la
ville une colonne de véhicules avec à
son bord des diplomates et des
journalistes
l'équipe britannique filmé les troupes
russes à ce moment là elles sont encore
à 10 km de la ville
des soldats qui arrête le pouvoir l'un
des chars pointe même sa tourelle sur la
voiture
puis ce sont des soldats qui les met en
joue ils arriveront finalement à passer
depuis le piège s'est refermé sur la
ville